hey what's up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to episode 10 of Network chat
programming so today we're gonna talk
about primarily a scroll pain okay
and I know that we're spending a lot of
time on this Jo I did Jui stuff but I
mean it's kind of important and also um
I'm just putting our basic details here
it's important and also it just it's
just needs to be covered and I've never
done a GOI kind of series before so
application development is going to be
like the series that covers that I guess
cuz you can see we're doing a lot of
stuff here I'm talking text here and
I've typed in a lot of conservative text
right and so when I scanned of start
exceeding and you can see here when um
when this kind of starts to get exceeded
and I start typing more stuff in it kind
of just pushes everything down and
that's not good okay there's no way for
us to scroll through this we want to
make a window kind of like this right
that we can scroll through just like
that so that's what we're going to talk
about today and then hopefully next time
next episode we'll actually be able to
move on to the the client server kind of
stuff okay hopefully so unless there's
something it is probably something else
that comes off of jr. because I'm doing
this kind of live so hopefully you're
not though hopefully everything will be
good so we have a text error called text
history yeah I'm not a big I'm I'm just
not a big fan of how when to build the
names things like we have this txt eye
history yeah like it's just not I don't
know it's just not very cool so what I
want to do is I want to refactor that
and what that means is I'm gonna
basically rename it so I'm gonna rename
it everywhere so instead of it being
called a text our history I'm just gonna
take I'm just gonna basically change it
into history right I'm gonna rename it
to history because where else are we
gonna use history Norway right it's just
gonna be a text area so I'm gonna right
click here and go refactor which is
right over here and then rename and I'm
gonna just basically just type here what
I want the new name to be which is
history hit enter and you're done okay
really really simple okay and effective
as you can see um now let's say here
what else is going down
we made in sets which is good I think
yeah okay we'll just do the pain now so
to make a scroll pain right what we need
to do here is uh basically just create
an object out of it of course first so J
scroll pain whoops
J scroll pain we'll call it a gold
scroll equals nu J Robin and of course
the parameter will be our little history
text area so that okay we'll have to
import that as well of course that's a
pretty standard procedure I'm sure
together
I used to that and what we have to do
next is kind of set the bounds of what
we want our scroll pain to be now this
is a like I mean hmm I'm just thinking
like it's not what we're doing here is
what it's actually really cool what
we're doing here is essentially we're
just saying okay we're kind of it's
almost like a canvas in a window okay
gives you guys used to game programming
you know we set the size of the canvas
blah blah and then we just pop it inside
it's out of the windows kind of what
we're doing okay
we're kind of doing the crowd the the
textarea stuff and then we're putting it
into a scroll thing and that's that
scroll pane is what gets rendered so
instead of adding
history here well we're actually doing
all we should be doing is something
completely different we should actually
just be adding this scroll pane okay now
this changes a lot of things namely
these grid back constraints what they
should be I don't know how I made that
character what it should be and if I
just go command shift ah no that's not
it is it alt shift oh okay I don't know
what it does a Mac I don't know what the
shortcut is for a factory well let's
refactor it again rename all okay it's
ctrl command off wait or option command
off anyway
we'll call this will call this scroll
constraints I guess okay so it
completely changed that and instead of
us over here basically well yeah that's
what we've done right and you can notice
over here that it's the same for
as it was before right and we don't have
to like set bounds or anything that we
could set bounds of course but we kind
of done that already
because we are we're giving it like a
grid coordinate but you know we'll see
it we'll see what it looks like just to
see what it looks like but what we've
done here is we've actually just put
this text area inside of a scroll pane
okay and of course we've done that by
calling the constructor with the text
area as a parameter so let's just run
this and see what happens so you know a
local host at one line - standard
procedure here hit login and you can see
first of all that it's worked straight
away you can see that we do see our
actual window here our text area now one
thing that's cool about this and one the
one that I guess the reason that really
you know you can see why it works is
because nowhere do we actually call this
history right if you actually just mouse
over history and you click on it you can
see all the all the users of it here
it's never actually added into our into
our J panel right into our content pane
here it's never actually added into it
all we've done is we've added it to a
scroll pain and that scroll pain seems
to be rendering so let's test out our
you know our awesome stuff here whoops
that's my keyboard get rid of the
illumination there and as you can see
awesomely enough it scrolls now and
there's a nice little scroll bar here
which actually will be which is
platform-independent so in other words
it'll actually match the style of your
platform because we are setting the UI
manager here to be our get system look
and feel class name and you can see what
we've done here is an awesome little and
make sure it's focused awesome little
thing that's called a scroll pen now one
thing that you can notice right away is
it doesn't actually scroll now okay
because if I click over here or whatever
and you know do stuff and then tie back
here it does scroll but occasionally it
won't the way that I like to do that is
I guess to always update the the caret
so there's one thing that we should
really be doing
so if I come over here into just just
over here I think I'll just make a
carrot okay and not a carrot isn't you
know card that you hate so that's bad ah
so private default carrot and I'll
explain what this is in case you guys
don't know and listen for that right
hopefully this works in um Mac actually
I've never tested this before max
probably well okay cool so what a carrot
is this little blinky thing that tells
us where we're typing so if we actually
set it equal to two this text area which
is called history dot get carrot right
and we'll actually have to cast that to
a default carrot because I think it just
returned the carrot yeah it does okay so
default oops
default carrot all right so we've cost
it here and now the beauty the beauty of
the thing that we can do now is we've
actually just gotten the carrot that we
get from the history so it's not visible
right because if we launch this little
little baby here you can see that once I
put in all those details we should
probably make some default details while
we're developing this we can't see where
we're currently typing here we count
over here you can see in the in the text
field that's because we've said it we've
I guess we've enabled it for editing
this is really only so we can't see it
blinking but it is still there and the
location of where it is is what
determines I guess what like you know
how we scroll because if I go down here
you know we'll scroll let's scroll back
up you can see it just keep going it
doesn't actually update this thing this
scroll is getting longer but it's not
actually updating and you can see in
right now it's not either because the
carrot stays here we've clicked we've
kind of like clicked and we put the
carrot over here so of course when we
update it's not gonna move the carrot
now if we were to do something like
carrot dot set update policy right to
default carrot dot always help me out
here I spelt the fault wrong that's
embarrassing dot always update ya then
always gonna update okay and it's always
gonna go to the position where the text
last appeared so again if I do type in
our details here and I do our stuff
we'll just get down so we can see how
that kind of works here and what I'll do
then is I'll scroll up and I'll click
over here and then I'll do this again
you can see that it doesn't actually
update now that was not what it was
supposed to do it might be I'm not sure
if this is a I'm not sure if this is a
platform dependent thing hmm right
I should probably investigate it a bit
further but hmm that's interesting you
know well let's try moving this carrot
card beneath this scroll just because I
think it adds it here am I not and what
kinda thing this will work but we could
try it out
because I'm pretty sure this works on
Windows just from memory
maybe maybe Mac is a bit less
sophisticated we'll say so we'll type in
our card of course oh well no no no I
carried I'll just write out random text
here and and then we'll scroll up we'll
click somewhere and we'll save that
updates okay and it's not luckily though
there is one more technique I know it's
it's probably not as clean but it does
work and we'll see if it even works on
so if it even works on um on Mac but the
thing is the other technique that we
could use here again from memory is if
we do log in every time we types in
something and we hit send what it's
doing is it's actually running our our
send method here right and the other
thing the other detail that we have is
really on only what you know it should
only scroll whenever it receives like a
new message so when it receives a new
message or when it actually when
something gets printed into this console
that's when it should you know reset the
caret position I can type out my
tutorials now so that being said what we
could do is simply say that when we do
do this right let's actually um grab a
little text area which is called history
and what we can do here is we can
actually
just simply set the Kara position to be
let's say if we get the length of the
thing and I think we have to get the
document first yep get length there it
is that should set that should actually
set our carrot position to be at the end
so let's try that out okay again no yarn
teaser tonight if this will work on Mac
it should be should even be working
normally but we'll see so I'm surprised
as the first method didn't work let's
scroll this stuff you know see what that
looks like and let's go up here click
somewhere and see what that works okay
that does work yeah you can see if we go
up to the top we click somewhere up here
we say something it immediately that
snaps to the bottom now that's um yeah
so it is quite weird that this technique
doesn't work on window on our Mac this
carrot default car I might have done
something I don't think so that looks
pretty right to me
so it is it is uh that that that remains
a mystery if anyone knows why I maybe
can let me know again I am primarily
windows developer but the point is no
hang on a minute we shouldn't do this
here okay this is a quick thing this is
sent okay the send thing is really what
happens when um when we when we send
things so in other words it won't work
for receiving well oh it will double up
Todd same code twice so let's actually
just move this one line of code down
into console because that's really
what's appending it to the thing so
again if we just verify that that does
work which it will by logging in here
and doing this stuff as usual come on
okay scroll up whoops scroll up click
somewhere okay it does work okay so
that's gonna wrap up episode 10 of a
network chat programming if I do look at
this little chat application that we've
made which is a pretty damn awesome if I
if I do say myself I think you're
resizing the resizing needs a bit of
work yeah there's a big gap here we'll
probably just do that I don't know I'm
one of the episodes but I'm going to
focus on reciting that that's Marvin I
said
and we'll do that later it is just a
quick fix you have to plan on the grid
back constrains in fact quickly just now
one thing that's interesting is um let's
say this uh so this grid x and y what if
we set these two to zero let's let's
just say what that looks like and also I
think we haven't set any weights before
all we haven't come ye team have we have
we because that that could be another
episode hmm okay everything yes okay
have we covered whites no we haven't
okay we need to talk about whites and
how they work with the grid back layout
so we'll do that in the next episode
Network shad programming thanks for
watching guys if you did go on to enjoy
the video well if you did enjoy it
please hit like button again to under
likes one video per day 300 likes two
videos per day and I will see you guys
in the next episode goodbye
Oh